let's talk about this trumpism article
this is an amazing article
from cnn how trumpism explains the
gamestop stock surge
uh spoiler alert it doesn't but uh let's
read anyway from chris seliza
he says at the core of donald trump's
angry populist appeal was and
is this sentiment quote the elites think
they know better than you
they think they can tell you how to live
and what to believe but guess what
we the people are smarter than the
elites let me stop you right there chris
the elites do think that and we the
people
as a decentralized distributed computing
network
are smarter than you it's why communism
doesn't work
because a committee can't figure out how
to distribute resources better
than a decentralized network of
individuals who are seeking the things
they need and want don't get me wrong
i'm not always a fair capitalist i think
there are still problems there
but yeah we see it in computing a
distributed network
is better than a single point of failure
i digress
he says trump elucidated this argument
in its purest form at a rally in north
dakota in 2018
when he went on his rift quote i meet
these people they call them the elite
these people i look at them i say that's
elite we got more money we got more
brains
we got better houses apartments we got
nicer boats we're smarter than they are
and they and they say they're elite
we're the elite you're the elite we're
the elite
so i said the other day let's keep
calling these people and let's face it
they've been stone cold losers the elite
the elite
so let them keep calling themselves the
elite but we're going to call ourselves
and remember you are indeed you work
harder but you are indeed smarter than
them
let's call ourselves from now on the
super elite we're the super elite
chris says what made trump's argument so
potent politically speaking
is that he wasn't just calling out the
elites he was saying that the average
joes needed to rise up and actually show
them how wrong they were
that voting for him voting him for him
was the best way to express their anger
and frustration
with the condescension of the alleged
bettors donald trump offered himself up
as a collective middle finger to the
elites and he won
all of which brings me to the current
seemingly inexplicable stock surge of
gamestop
the video game seller that has made its
money over the years thanks to its
location in malls now from here we get
kind of the point
i got to tell you for the most part he's
bringing up the correct point in kind of
the wrong way
it's not trumpism trump did not create
this
trump is a symptom of this guess what
the elites have been saying we're
smarter than you
they have been using revolving door
politics where the people from the
biggest corporations get the jobs in
government overseeing the same company
they just worked for a ceo or starting
wars and selling the bombs
from government back to their friends
those companies we know what they do and
we know the games they play we know the
bailouts they get
when they fail they they say oh well we
have to save them they're too big but
when mom and pop shops fail
they say sorry too bad why don't you
apply for unemployment maybe six months
we'll kick you a check that doesn't
isn't enough to buy a loaf of bread
more importantly let's even talk about
schools i'm not a fan of college but
they're they are telling these people
your only choice is to go to college
racking up massive debt for young people
who find no way out the system is
crumbling
the elites have been milking it and
extracting it forever
and it's gotten to the point where
people are saying enough and now the
best part is
the left and the right are both laughing
as this happens but to claim it's
trumpism no you see
trump was the imperfect avatar for
people who felt this anger
but there are people who couldn't agree
with his policies as a man
he couldn't represent this this entity
well enough
with trump gone that entity is now in
its purest form the rage
of the people staring at the elites who
have been stripping out their value and
kicking them down and mocking them
is now just been unleashed and this is
what we got like obi-wan kenobi man
yes struck him down that was a being of
light chris the author of this article
actually tweeted it
and the number one response right now is
a picture of ralph with a flute in his
nose
with a thousand five hundred likes uh
right now and i'm reading some of the
replies
and uh a lot of people are just like
what are you
talking about and and you're right he
had a hard time explaining what was
happening so he just
did the laziest thing he could and said
it's just it's all because of this one
guy trump-ism
i want to share this story i'm not
endorsing what i'm about to share the
story
but i live in middle america i live in
tennessee i live in nashville
and the problem with a lot of the media
they live in new york or l.a
they're totally disconnected from real
people i live in nashville right
downtown
it's a very popular bar across street
for me i went and watched sunday
football
there was a young man in the bar wearing
a hat
and he was with a big group of people
and he walked
by to go to the bathroom i said what's
on your hat and it said make politicians
afraid again
and that's the sentiment you have
in the south in tennessee where
nashville is a relatively uh
liberal city it's had a liberal mayor a
democratic mayor
since like the 1960s or 70s but that
guy's sentiment on his hat that he's
wearing out
in a crowded bar everybody watching
football no one bats an
eye at thinking like that and so
you're right again trump
imperfect avatar but the
if we let people express their anger
through the ballot
it's a lot better than these other
methods that they're going to go to
and if we don't restore some integrity
in our election process
we're just you know we're headed for
civil conflict well i got this quote
this is uh the four boxes of liberty
which we briefly mentioned
they say larry mcdonald a politician
from georgia and former president of
john birch society
has also been quoted omitting the
caution to use bullets as the last
resort quote
we have four boxes with which to defend
our freedom the soap box
the ballot box the jury box and the
cartridge box
the term is used in newspaper articles
and has been used in a petition of the
supreme court of california
four boxes and derivatives have been
used the name of various websites that
espouse patriotism and the right to bear
arms
i have i think there's a better quote um
that's probably safer to use
those that make peaceful revolution
impossible make violent revolution
inevitable and that was we talked about
kennedy and so it's similar when people
soap box and they stand up and say this
must happen and then big tech
bashes them over the head and knocks
them to the dirt well then
they go to the ballot box they cast
their votes then we saw trump bring
people to the jury box
sort of they went to the courts they
tried to they tried and then what we saw
was people storm the capital so it's a
low-grade version and it's scary because
we don't want conflict we want people to
like figure out a path forward
but i tell you right now what we're
seeing with this
this gamestop wall street stuff is
populist anger
you know what's funny is there are a lot
of establishment democrat types who are
scared of the word populist
they don't know what it means you're
either a populist or you're an elitist i
understand it's not absolute but the
general idea is
for of and by the people or for the
establishment elites the cronies
the people with the money the people
born in the wealth tip the way i i
look at populism is popular ideas for
the pop for for the population ideas
that the people want and need
so when you have the left and the right
completely disagreeing on how to
implement the policies to make things
better
but completely agreeing the
establishment is crooked and corrupt and
cheering this on
well then we are seeing some kind of
raw unified force it's not going to be
it's not going to be politically unified
because that's that you know the
politics the political parties and the
ideologies
are more of effigies or avatars of this
this ideology or anger now what we're
seeing now is pure rage
like when you see people go out in the
street and riot pure rage there's
nothing there's no rhyme or reason
what we're seeing now with wall street
bets is just digital it's online it's
more strategic
but a lot of people are throwing their
money behind this not expecting it rich
tim do you think because my concern
as a black person is i'm wondering
it's like when i'll have a conversation
with my mother about
all of this and she's so into
democratic politics she's such a barack
ob
i'm not even sure if she fully
understands
what's going on in this country as it
relates to working class versus the
elite my mother was a 30-year factory
worker she is
as working-class as it comes but she's
so into democratic politics
that i think she thinks she's an elite
because of the life that i provide her
probably
but i think she thinks she's an elite
and everything to her
or i don't want to speak for but for a
lot of black people everything comes
down to race
trump supporters they're racist so it
doesn't matter
that they stormed the capitol and
confronted white politicians
that was racism that was it's the divide
and conquer
now first i'll say it again because i
think they accomplished nothing by doing
this for me the capital
but divide and conquer man when we had
occupy wall street
luke and i met at occupy wall street and
we're like on on you know mere images
idea
we both with the political compass task
test i'm center left luke center right
but we met at the same place because
occupy wall street attracted libertarian
types
right and caps and arco communist
leftists
but something disrupted all that
identity politics
that came in and dominated the
discussion and it pushed out
anybody else who might actually align
and so that that
that was divide and conquer yeah i mean
that's why a few weeks ago we were
talking about this and i'm like
there's going to be a huge
anti-establishment
swell that's going to come after people
realize about how
joe biden is invested in the special
interests that don't serve them that
screw the american people
i think we're seeing the first steps of
this and i think we still have a lot
more to go
a lot more to do and i think this is
going to become more and more prevalent
as we're going to see this kind of new
emergence
of a new kind of occupy wall street
populist movement that's going to be
against the establishment
we're seeing it here i mean i was
telling you it's going to happen a few
weeks ago
i think we're at the beginning of it it
might be the stock thing it might be
another thing but i i think we're headed
towards a lot of people being extremely
discontent with the current system
realizing it organizing and moving
forward i mean we're seeing almost
close to civil wars breaking out in
places like holland right now
over of course the lockdown issues and
that's only just one issue out of many
issues that people are getting screwed
over with look at vladimir putin saying
in davos
were were in an era that was just like
pre-world war ii
and so we're dangerously close to
something truly traumatic and
devastating in this planet
we talked about this before the mass
printing of money do you know that
somewhere around like 60 to 66 percent
of all u.s dollars were printed in the
past like 10 months
around around that never happened before
and so you have to imagine there's going
to be some rapid and dramatic
instability
or mass divide between the rich and the
poor getting worse
economic inequality leads to serious
economic instability
angry poor people come up come out show
up with pitchforks when they realize
there's no path forward for them
and that if you're gonna you know you
look at some of these places where
there's oligarchy
san francisco is essentially a big tech
oligarch you got there's so much human
waste littering the streets of san
francisco you heard about
you know about this story san francisco
has their own poop department
it's funny right ha ha we left no it's
it's serious might
you know you can say that chicago's got
a chicago fire department they got the
chicago pd
and then you can say they got animal
control whatever public services san
francisco has a poop department
they deploy people to clean human waste
off the streets but they have some of
the most well
the wealthiest individuals on the planet
living in the bay area
and working in these areas how can that
be the the the divide is
massive people start to realize that the
wealthy elites are rigging the game to
make sure they never lose
and you never win and then people are
going to lose it yeah they're going to
get mad
now because i'm basically going to
reiterate a point we made earlier
but now looking at how people are like
oh we can play this wall street game too
right
nope they'll change the rules on you yep
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time